je vous le disais en titre le congrès
national des hlm s'est ouvert ce matin
marseille c'est un congrès qui s'annonce
morose puisque l'existence même des
habitations à loyer modéré paraît être
en cause ou en tout cas menacé les hlm
sont appelés à disparaître petit à petit
et en se fondant dans l'ensemble des
promotions immobilières ou ont-elles
encore un rôle social à jouer l'exemple
de l'île de france
il y à 80 mille logements hlm dans la
région 65 mille d'entre eux sont
construits à paris pour des milliers de
familles les hlm ont été la possibilité
de quitter des taudis misérable
surpeuplées et d'accéder à un confort
élémentaire sans doute aujourd'hui n'y
at il plus aucune mesure entre la crise
du logement de 1950 et les besoins
actuels encore qu à ce jour ils sont des
milliers dans la région qui sont
inscrits au fichier des mal-logés 35000
pour un département comme le val de
marne
aujourd'hui trois questions se posent
aux hlm la première est de savoir si
l'urgence et quantitatives ou
qualitatives
l'image des clapiers sonneurs et autres
cages à lapins aura du mal à s'estomper
de l'imagerie populaire seconde question
des hlm pour qui le logement social en
ile de france comme ailleurs a dû faire
face à des bouleversements administratif
et financier
autrefois l'aide publique n'avait qu'une
forme l'aide à la pierre
l'état financé en fonction du type de
construction hln lily allen et serra
aujourd'hui si cette aide demeure elle a
diminué pour faire place à une aide
personnalisée cette nouvelle forme dead
et plus justes puisque l'offre une
subvention plus forte aux plus pauvres
mais les responsables chez l'homme
redoutent qu'elle n'entraîne une
augmentation des loyers et surtout
qu'elles excluent des hlm une catégorie
moyenne de locataires ceux qui n'ont pas
assez d'argent pour acquérir une
propriété métro pour percevoir une aide
sociale
conséquence l'aide à la personne ne
risque-t-elle pas d'aller à l'encontre
de son but en créant une ségrégation
enfin troisième question et paris comme
la région ils sont particulièrement
sensibles le prix du terrain dans les
villes étant ce qu'il est comment les
sociétés hlm peuvent-elles reconquérir
salariés les plus modestes sont ils
voués à la migration quotidienne travail
domicile telles sont les questions
posées à marseille et qui intéresse
l'île de france au premier chef cet
après midi au congrès hlm monsieur dan
au ministre de l'environnement a
renouvelé la confiance du gouvernement
envers les offices hlm et annoncé la
réalisation d'un programme banlieue